[Music]
yes
there's one way in and one way out and
it's across this pontoon bridge
the people who live in the town of
krimska right on the demarcation line
are utterly dependent on this ice and
snow-covered road
kept open by the ukrainian military
a couple of drivers are prepared to
ferry people and supplies to the
residents who have stayed throughout the
fighting in eastern ukraine
just hundreds are here now it used to be
thousands
it's part town part barracks
normal life has been suspended
the scars of the war that began with the
russian-backed separatist uprising in
2014 are everywhere
the people live in the midst of
destroyed homes and businesses not
targeted
just bombed out of existence
the war dominates life here
an armored ambulance heads out to pick
up a casualty on the front line it's on
the edge of town
the countryside on three sides of
krimska is mined
the trenches separating the two sides
are static although the firing between
them happens every day
sniper fire is a constant danger so
keeping low
is essential for everyone
well we're driving around in two uh
locally hired largers
um
not the greatest car i've ever been in
but it does the job and the guys who
drive it basically they're the link for
the village to the outside world
and the truck that we use is actually
big and it's white and it would it's a
definite um strange vehicle to be here
so they said go low profile use local
people
our other car stays behind so we
basically um
come in with all our kits and put it
into the back of the cars i'm surprised
it fits
the people of krimska are the poor and
the old
in this freezing environment they depend
on charities bringing fuel food and
medicine
trucks carrying compressed fuel
briquettes dump their loads on the side
of the road
the most able-bodied gathered to
distribute it to the most needy
slipping and sliding on makeshift
sledges
or humping it on wheelbarrows
life here is really hardcore with um
obviously getting fuel at this time of
year is absolutely vital and this is a
logs that have been dropped off by the
charity characters but what's
interesting we've come to meet jana
she's here with her family
basically everyone needs help from the
outside world and uh
we'd arrange to meet them but here they
are all ready so we'll be going into
their houses uh skid kids are off school
because of uh uh have covered and
obviously the whole place is pretty much
deserted because of the war so sort of
double whammy that's taking place at the
moment
jana took us to the family home it was
bombed out in the fighting but they've
rebuilt it
she has three boys and a daughter
her eldest son is on the front line with
the army
[Music]
ten-year-old vika can't remember life
when there wasn't a war
she is a remarkably talented artist her
still life takes pride of place in the
living room
where she studies
kovit has struck krimska so school is
closed
vika is typical of frontline children
they accept the war but they're scarred
by it
i asked her to describe her life to a
ten-year-old girl in britain
this is
do you um
perhaps look at the television or or on
the internet and think i wouldn't mind
my life to be like
someone else's life in another country
yes
sir
there's only one medical facility in
krimska and it's a military field
hospital right in the center of town
they've been here for years in many ways
they're an essential part of life a
medical link to the outside world
they live in an underground basement
above them is the only shop in town
it's run by lena parhamenko
eight times she's had to replace every
window in her home because of the
shelling
she simply won't leave her business
krimska depends on her
but lena is actually russian
in a conflict dominated by
misinformation
she's often at loggerheads with her
family back home
okay
the psychological effect on the front
line children in this war is difficult
to gauge
when they're very little they can't
necessarily express their trauma
actually adults aren't much different
but they develop better coping
mechanisms through age
the voices of children charity has an
art therapy project
it employs psychologists to help these
little ones
left to draw what they want there is a
clear link between fighting and the talk
of fighting in their artwork
look how this turns black
it doesn't need explaining
the cycle has started again
foreign
has one school
84 students have been reduced to 18.
the families have gone because of
fighting
now covet has closed it just the
teachers are here now
yes
war and covid have changed everything in
krimska
and those who have stayed may not have
given up
but they're on their knees really
surviving but only that
survivor
[Music]